now look you've done so much i i
couldn't believe how much you've done i
mean mulan and agents of the shield and
joy luck club and street fighter and
mandalorian and now the book of boba
fett and er and it goes on and on and on
and
you don't look old enough to have done
all this first of all
but you you're in the marvel universe
star wars star gate
i mean you're kind of living the dream
in a bit i mean you're living my dream
what does it feel like to have done all
this stuff yeah i i don't know i pinch
myself every day i don't
i i mean i'm just always so thankful
for all of it is that how you go about
no it really shouldn't happen
to
well you know the double minority right
asian woman
and now you know ageism i mean it
shouldn't be happening like really
to someone like me
who had to learn a second language you
know coming from a different country
like if if it's any
um
if it means anything to anyone because
it means so much to me but if it means
anything to anyone that you can achieve
and fulfill your dreams
it's that you know just
it's truly like the american dream story
it is the american dream story it's just
a great it's a great dream i mean it's
it's it's a reality for you and it's
it is it's amazing you deserve it all
right it's kind of crazy i i really it's
still it's sort of like an out of body
experience and i can't explain it any
other way like
every time i look at pictures you know
you go to work as a professional right
you go to work it's your job you've got
to i mean i geek out for about 5-10
minutes when i'm on set because there's
always these new toys right you know and
these new images and
and so
i'm always like
like a kid in a candy store just going
crazy and then i got to remind myself oh
wait well tim
tamura
he'll remind me but